and you you just heard at least trust
offering uh the prime minister her full
support i i suspect i know the answer to
this one but but you find yourself in
the same position 100 behind the prime
minister
what we do know are what has been
alleged since the minister was on the
program yesterday morning are these
these allegations of blackmail of
improper coercion uh of improper
pressure being exerted by by the whips
office the prime minister hadn't had a
chance to to look at those reports
yesterday morning he will have done by
now what is the conclusion i don't know
what the conclusion is um certainly i've
been an mp for 12 years now and i've
never heard of the kind of allegations
that are being made
uh blackmail the idea that somehow money
is being uh withheld from communities
that need it uh on account of the
behavior of the mps i've never heard of
anything like that i i find it strange
because the whips office doesn't
actually have the power over spending in
that way but obviously we're going to
take the allegations seriously and we
need to look uh to the bottom of it you
know that the whips office doesn't have
responsibility for for
attributing funding i know that
the mps that will have been spoken to by
the wips office will all have been aware
of that as well isn't the the
insinuation is that the whips are
operating you know under the guidance or
at least with the tacit acceptance that
is going on of those at the top of those
in number 10. well as i said they're not
responsible and you've accepted that
they're not responsible for dispersing
actual money because i don't see how uh
they they could make those uh
allegations but i've never heard those
uh those threats i've never heard of
that i'm just
pretty straightforward isn't it they
threatened to withhold funding as indeed
uh the former conservative mp now labour
mp for berry has suggested they've
threatened to withhold funding and the
reason that mps are reacting to those
threats is they presume that they're
coming with the approval of people more
senior than the website so
in terms of how the whipping operation
works
it's really important that the whips
actually get on with mps it's a really
important
relationship
so i was very surprised to see the
allegations uh i haven't seen any
evidence uh to back them up but
obviously we have to look and see you
know what's actually gone on what what
what is what would your mind is
acceptable conduct on behalf of the
whips office to what extent can they go
to try and get the castleton mps to fall
into line and do what they want
obviously in any parliamentary democracy
you've got whips who are
trying to enforce party discipline who
are talking to
mps talking to parliamentarians and
they're trying to persuade people
to follow
uh the government line or the party line
so that we can get legislation through
the parliament
but allegations of of of blackmail and
intimidation uh are completely uh very
unusual i've never heard
such allegations and i think it would be
unacceptable well how then to account
for for stories which are appearing in
the papers about those rebels who have
indicated their intention to rebel
adahanna davison for example a number of
allegations thrown up a number of
comments you know insinuations about her
sexuality insinuations about her
relationship with alcohol i mean are
those acceptable
look i think in any uh system
political system that we have there are
lots of briefings all the time that are
being made i don't know who's making the
briefings um lots of things are said
lots of accusations about colleagues are
made but as far as the allegation the
specific allegation about whips
withholding funds i think that's
completely unacceptable
i think any form of blackmail and
intimidation of that kind uh is simply
has no place in british politics
those allegations give me i don't i
don't think i don't think uh it's it's
it's it's something that i've ever heard
of i don't think that this is happening
but it's certainly incredibly serious
i'll ask the question again i mean what
what what would happen what should
happen actually in your view if these
allegations are substantiated look i
don't want to get drawn into what will
happen if unsubstantiated allegations
have proven true all i would like to say
is that it's completely unacceptable and
we need to get to the bottom of the
matter but i find it unlikely uh frankly
given the nature what i know of the
whips given what i know of how the
parliament works today i'd find it very
unlikely that these allegations are true
let's talk briefly then about about sue
gray and there are a number of reports
this morning suggesting that she has
uncovered an email warning martin
reynolds to cancel the party if that is
confirmed the prime minister has to go
doesn't he no i don't think uh that's
the case at all no again we're
pre-judging i know people want to um
come to conclusions uh before
uh
we we can do so we've got to see what
sugray says and then once the report is
out
we can draw our own conclusions as the
prime minister has consistently said the
prime minister's also said a number of
things which seem to run counter to the
idea that there was indeed a warning
that this party should not go ahead
because it was a party and he has said
that he received no warning i mean if if
he is shown to have either misled the
house
or indeed lied as as steve baker has
said he has to go doesn't he so
as i said before i think we've got to
wait to the report
let's see what sue gray says and then
after that i'm sure the prime minister
will make a statement
why do you have to wait for the report
to answer a question
as straightforward as if the prime
minister has misled the house or the
prime minister has lied he has to go but
why is it that an impossible constant
answer right now the answer is obvious
isn't it
consistently we've said consistently
that we will wait uh for sue gray's
report i know you're trying to ask me
hypothetical questions if this happens
and if that happens uh should the prime
minister say
it's a binary answer does the prime
minister have to resign if he's proved
to have mislead the house i mean in
other times
you wouldn't i wouldn't have had to push
you for an answer so all i all i want to
say is in this specific instance we have
a report
and i want to see the report before we
make any further uh uh further
statements
i mean
i mean one of the one of the accusations
that has been made of christian wakeford
is that he has been some in some manner
attention seeking by alleging that not
just was funding for a school in his
constituency threatened to be withheld
but also there was some suggestions that
boundary changes could be made that
would be detrimental to his continuing
i mean the person who success
him of attention seeking was you know
one nadine doris who appeared and i'm a
celebrity for goodness sakes i don't
know about what his motivations were i
think you'd have to ask christian why he
defected or why he essentially uh
changed uh uh you know turn coats and
changed his political allegiance that's
a matter for him i don't know what his
motivations uh were um and as you will
appreciate he's a labour mp now and of
course you know his job part of his job
is to try and uh discredit the
government i fully accept that but you'd
have to ask him as to why he he defected
i i wonder if we can just turn just
briefly on to on to covet um and of
course there are
there have been a number of changes that
have been announced a number of changes
that will take place over the next few
weeks specifically on the issue of
masquerading in schools
we are seeing a number of reports now
that despite the
the direction from central government
there will be a number of schools still
insisting on children wearing masks in
environments which the prime minister
says they don't have to anymore what
should happen in those schools what
should the parents of those children do
i think that they should um
follow
official guidance now how the schools
run as far as i'm concerned um you know
that's a matter also for teachers and
parents to negotiate but the guidance
from the prime minister is very clear
that we won't need to be wearing masks
so just to be very specific on this
point
schools which are telling their pupils
that they should continue to wear masks
they are wrong
uh i all i say is that they have to uh
follow the guidance but i'm not going to
be i'm not here what happens if they
don't i'm not here as a business
secretary i understand i'm not here as
the business secretary responsible for
the economy
which i thought we might be talking
about
to enforce uh to tell uh school teachers
and head teachers how they're gonna run
run schools that's i'm afraid not my
remit
okay one one thing which will be your
remit is encouraging civil servants
working at your department absolutely
come back and be back at their desk when
will we be back to normal levels i'm
hopeful that we can do this as quickly
as possible we're talking to our work
staff particularly in phase in my
department
and i've said that people should start
getting back to normal as soon as they
can
the hospitality industry though calling
for a return to emergency outdoor dining
rooms on the high street i mean we
understand that there may be another a
few other measures being looked at at
the moment perhaps an extension more
grant money perhaps extension on tax
relief but what is your understanding is
there going to be anything more for the
hospitality industry i think we've
provided very liberally for the sector
over the last two years the chance has
been extremely generous with furlough
schemes they've had a business rates uh
holiday many uh businesses they've also
had a vat
holiday as well so there's been huge
support something like 400 billion
pounds over the last uh
18 months or so has been put into the
economy and obviously i speak to
hospitality leaders all the time and i'm
suggesting that uh you know what has
been the great success is the vaccine
rollout that's managed to keep the
economy going and all the hospitality
leaders the the ceos the people who run
these companies have said the one thing
that will destroy the hospitality sector
is a return to lockdown we've avoided
that through the vaccine rollout
we've got one of the most open economies
in the world at the moment and also
we're seeing a very fast growth rate so
all of that's incredibly encouraging and
i think hospitality leaders people in
the sector are very happy that we've
avoided uh the lockdowns well that was
close enough to an answer that i am
going to move straight on to your brief
advice and you can explain to me what a
giga factory might be it's going to be
something which is going to be very
important to our economy moving forward
some will be wondering why perhaps
government funds were necessary for its
construction so the reason why there has
been some government money put into this
is that we're in a global race every
advanced manufacturing country in the
world wants to attract people to build
as you say these gigafactories and what
the gigafactory is is simply
a manufacturing facility for batteries
and batteries power electric vehicles
and uh people know that electric
vehicles are the new coming uh form of
transport people are transforming their
lives by buying these things and they're
running essentially on electricity this
is something that's happening all over
the world and clearly uh manufacturing
countries like ourselves like germany
france others want to be able to
manufacture
batteries for electric vehicles because
they can see the demand for them and the
announcement we made yesterday i was up
in
blythe near newcastle uh is hugely
significant i mean it creates something
like 3000 immediate jobs on the site and
then 5 000 jobs locally an extra 5 000
jobs for what we call the supply chain
the companies that make the materials
that feed into the factory so why then
the needs for you know
i mean reports vary but it seems to be a
figure of around about 100 million
pounds worth of government money is
being put into this so we put in then
the need we put in 10 million tens of
millions the actual amount of money
that's being invested is uh more than
north of 2.5 billion pounds so there's a
huge leverage in terms of for every
pound we're putting in we're getting 25
pounds of private investment and as i
said the reason why we've put a little
bit of government money into this is
that this is a global competition every
other country advanced manufacturing
country is giving subsidies is giving
breaks uh to
uh uh companies to invest in electric
vehicle manufacturing and this is a once
in a generation opportunity if you
haven't got any ability to make electric
vehicles uh
that you you're never going to build
that and you've got one opportunity to
do that in the early 2020s